in this video we will study about the
male reproductive system the male
reproductive system consists of the
external sex organs which include the
penis' and the scrotum and the internal
sex organs which include the testes
epididymis vas deferens seminal vesicle
and the prostate gland first let's talk
about the external sex organs the penis'
is the male external organ that serves
as a common pathway for urine and the
semen the penis' is made up of glands
root and the body the root of the penis
is the part which attaches the penis to
the body the root of the Bennis lies in
the superior very near pouched to
understand the structure of the body of
the penis let's look at a cross-section
of the body it consists of three columns
of tissues two corpora cavernosa on the
dorsal side and one corpus spongiosum on
the ventral side the corpora cavernosa
are columns of erectile tissue that have
spaces or caverns in between them that
get filled with blood and erect the
penance the corpora cavernosa also
contain deep arteries in them the corpus
spongiosum is a column of spongy tissue
the male urethra passes in between
corpus spongiosum the glans is the
enlarged corpus spongiosum at one end it
is covered with four skin called prepuce
the next external reproductive organ is
the scrotum
the scrotum is a pouch like structure
made up of skin that has two main
functions it protects the testes and
maintains a scrotal temperature which
has two to three degree Celsius
temperature lower than the body
temperature which is very important for
the process of spermatogenesis
the scrotum also contains numerous blood
vessels and nerves the Cree master
muscle present in the scrotum contracts
and pulls the scrotum closer to the body
whenever the outside temperature falls
too low thus maintaining a
and scrotal temperature now let's talk
about the internal reproductive organs
and the first internal reproductive
organ that will discuss is the testes
the testes is the main male reproductive
organ that has two main functions the
first is to produce the male gametes
that are the sperms and second is a
production of male reproductive hormone
that is a testosterone the testes has an
outer covering called uni cobalt in a
list that is an extension of the
peritoneum and an inner covering called
tunica albuginea does is thicker and is
made up of dense connective tissue the
tunica albuginea sends various septae in
the parenchyma of the testes which
divides the testes into numerous low
pills these lobules contain seminiferous
tubules seminiferous tubules are highly
coiled tube like structures now let's
look at the structure of the wall of a
seminiferous tubules as you can see the
wall of the seminiferous tubules
contains three types of cells the Leydig
cells sertoli cells and the germ cells
the Ladak cells have the primary
function of production of the hormone
testosterone the germ cells
differentiate towards the lumen of the
seminiferous tubules too immature or
sperms and the sertoli cells have a
function to protect and provide growth
to the developing germ cells now let's
talk about the next internal
reproductive organ that is the
epididymis the epididymis is a highly
coiled tube like structure which
connects the testes to the vas deferens
the epididymis is made up of the
following paths the head the body and
the tail the immature sperms produced in
the seminiferous tubules pass to the
epididymis via the efferent DuckTales
these immature sperms travel towards the
tail of the epididymis and go through
the process of maturation during this
process of maturation the immature
sperms become mature and gain the
properties like motility and fertility
the next internal reproductive organ is
the vas deferens the vas deferens is
also known as the ductus deferens the
ductus deferens is a 30 centimeter long
tube that connects the epididymis to the
ejaculatory duct the wall of vas
deferens is lined by smooth
that helps the passage of sperm through
its lumen next internal reproductive
organ is the seminal vesicle which is
small secretory gland that connected to
the vas deferens by a small duct the
main function of seminal vesicle is that
it produces the seminal fluid that mixes
with the sperms and forms a semen this
fluid is alkaline which prolongs the
survival of the sperms
as the environment inside the vagina is
acidic the final internal reproductive
organ is the prostate gland the prostate
lies below the bladder and the main
function of prostate in the reproduction
is that it produces alkaline fluid that
forms 30% of the total semen volume this
fluid improves the survival and motility
of the sperm so this was a brief
overview about the male reproductive
system thank you so much for watching
this video like our channel on YouTube
for all the upcoming videos and make
sure to LIKE our channel on Facebook for
flashcards and upcoming notifications